elena
is with us and uh elena is in
new york hi elena how are you
i'm good um how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
um so i am 16 years old and
i want to know what your advice is on me
buying my first car
um i have to buy my own first car but my
parents are paying for my insurance
um i start my minimum wage job next week
and so after that i'll be saving
pretty much everything i make because i
don't have any expenses right now
okay so my sister is a year older than
me and she saved for a year and she was
able to save around
six thousand and she put that towards a
car and now she's paying payments on it
but i know you're wondering because i i
take um a personal finance class in
school
and i've been watching your videos for
forever and i know you don't like doing
payments on a car and that you like
paying for cash i was wondering what
would be your advice for me trying to
buy my first car well if i had six
thousand dollars i would buy six
thousand dollar car
okay and that way you don't have
payments you know
i know that sounds simplistic but that's
really what it is and
the other thing i would do is think
about what you can do that makes you the
most
money for the hours you spend you might
be able to do better than minimum wage
babysitting a lot of babysitters are
making 15 20 bucks an hour
you know and so you know i don't know
it's not it's not like these are
your career choices what you're gonna do
the rest of your life you're just trying
to get some money together
to buy a car and so i'm looking for the
job that as long as it's a moral
job and it's safe for you i'm looking
for the thing that pays me the most
if i'm in your shoes and so i would
consider doing that
and uh work that out and you know decide
from there but
you know you can do the minimum wage if
you want but i i'm gonna save up
and pay cash for whatever i do
and the other thing is this shop around
and learn about the different cars
which ones have higher insurance rates
some of them have a higher rate of theft
and so they have a very high insurance
rate some of them have a higher rate of
getting wrecked
uh and so that particular car might cost
twice as much as another car is the same
price range
to ensure at your age so make sure you
investigate
the insurance rates on the car you're
thinking about buying as well